[Music]
the year 2020 is the 250th anniversary
of beethoven's birth
and germany is ready to celebrate
but nowhere more so than his hometown of
bonn
this great big story was made possible
by the german national tourist board
beethoven lived more than 22 years in
bonn and there are many places here that
are associated with beethoven
my name is marty burkha i'm the director
of the beethoven house we're in front of
the beethoven house beethoven's
birthplace in 1770
and it's considered one of the best
visited music museums in the world
i'm standing in front of the beethoven
monument and it's the first monument
dedicated to beethoven ever and we are
very proud to have a tien bon
this is one of 22 installations and this
is our form of presenting the beethoven
city bond to the world
i think he'd be pretty
happy to see that his music is still
relevant is still performed
and he would encourage us to look to the
future
[Music]
the city of bond during the day is
beautiful but at night it really shines
in honour of beethoven's 250th
anniversary the city of bonn in germany
is lighting up the night with some
installations inspired by him and his
workshops
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
philippe
from sight to sound one woman is uniting
with composers across the globe to
curate and perform 250 original
compositions inspired by beethoven's
work
having born in the focus of contemporary
composers is the best thing you could
give beethoven as a birthday gift
my name is susana kessel i'm a concert
pianist i'm organizing and managing the
project 250 piano pieces for beethoven
in 2020 the large beethoven anniversary
will take place and as a bond citizen i
wanted to do a large project for him
i thought of asking 250 composers all
over the world for personal commissions
for piano pieces that refer to
beethoven's music or his personality or
his deafness all composers were free to
do what they like
i always perform other people's music
and this is something that makes me
really really happy of course that
through beethoven people
have the connection to new music
[Music]
the music continues outside of bonn with
some curious self-playing instruments
located in germany there is a museum of
antique self-playing mechanical music
instruments where you can hear
beethoven's classical orchestral
arrangements played
[Music]
i belong to
siegfried's mechanical music cabinet
they were the first possibility to
listen to music without the help of a
human being
and as a composer
to write music and have it played
exactly like you wanted to the oldest
instrument is from 1780
and it's a clear maya flute clock
fairground organ is one of the most
favorite the hopfelt funnelist violina
plays six violins at the same time
together with piano
usually people don't know about these
instruments anymore and it's a lot of
dancing and singing it's more fun in
here
and finally two performers who celebrate
beethoven every day by reimagining his
works with one piano and four hands
we want to combine piano and
entertainment and make classical pieces
more accessible to the audience
we are pia entertainment marcel don and
stefan v we perform all over the world
in more than 100 countries till now
beethoven is one of the most famous
composers and he gave so much to the
world with his music and now we live in
2020 and it's the beethoven year that's
a great chance to bring his work back
on stage in our way four-handed show
elements and
a bit more funny than he was himself
the audience is amazed how we put
together old beethoven with a new style
of latin of sambar etc
sharing an instrument you have to be
like series twins four hands
one piano one artist
[Music]
you